when I was in college and money was
tight I sold my World of Warcraft
character I remember that
didn't you meet like three to 50 bucks
we gave him a system babe I thought so
too but if you add up what it cost me to
get there fifty dollars to buy the game
$30 for the expansion pack $15 a month
subscription fee under a few years of
that right so around $500 into that one
game not to mention the countless hours
I'd spent leveling up my character hikes
well at least you were able to mitigate
the loss a bit and you genuinely enjoyed
playing it right I think so was it just
addicted remember when buying a
videogame meant you owned it and you
could play the whole thing without
spending one more dime ah the good old
days that sales model has been largely
replaced by one that asks players to
continuously pay money throughout the
course of the game and that economic
transition has been very lucrative for
the games industry if you asked an 80's
gamer to spend five hundred thousand
dollars on a video game they'd probably
choke on their Hawaiian Punch
but today millions of players do that
every year perhaps without even
realizing it how did we get here
the first free-to-play game was released
in South Korea in 1999 and over the next
decade the idea spread across the globe
as developers realize that capturing a
large audience could be more valuable
than any purchase price kind of how the
rest of the internet works once you have
their attention then you can advertise
to them or sell them little upgrades and
cosmetic items in game these so called
micro transactions have been incredibly
profitable remember farmville this free
game was making well over 1 million
dollars a day from in-game upgrades and
boosts back in 2010 the current
free-to-play champ fortnight reportedly
brings in over 2 million dollars a day
and remember unlike material goods these
products cost the company no
to manufacture once the cost of design
is offset it's pure profit so how do
these companies pull off this nifty
trick of getting people to overspend on
something that's technically free like
most marketing the strategy is based on
exploiting the customers psychology
first of all if you want people to keep
spending you need to keep them playing
which means these games have to be
open-ended and addictive forget beating
the final boss or rescuing the princess
now it's all about climbing the
leaderboard raising your level or
expanding your kingdom objectives that
could theoretically go on forever and
the distribution of awards like
unlocking a new weapon or a vapor castle
has been carefully crafted in look sound
and timing to deliver a powerful
dopamine rush that players will crave
again and again developers also know
that as much as people like winning they
hate losing more in economics this is
called loss aversion and it leads people
to spend more and more money just to
avoid that terrible feeling of being a
loser in candy crush once you run out of
moves you've technically lost but you
can use one lollipop to get three extra
turns and you've only got a few seconds
to decide hurry before it's too late
this may not seem that different from
the earliest days of video games where
players could pump another quarter into
the arcade cabinet to keep playing but
at least you could run out of quarters
in half time we think your life goals on
the way to the change machine today
those little arcade cabinets we keep in
our pockets are often linked to our bank
accounts so you can keep continuing and
continuing until there's nothing left
quarters also had the advantage of
saying exactly how much they're worth
right on the front many of today's games
require you to convert your money into
unfamiliar currencies like court nights
v bucks or league of legends riot points
they know people are more likely to
spend money if they don't know exactly
how much they're spending the newest
innovation in microtransactions
seems to be inspired from the casinos of
Las Vegas loot boxes
all legendary oh yes instead of selling
items outright some games ask you to buy
a mystery box that might contain a super
rare level 20 energy sword or a
worthless stick loot boxes card packs
and other random chance items exploit
what economists call variable rate
enforcement our brains love
unpredictable rewards
just like with slot machines the
dopamine rush is more intense when the
reward is a surprise so opening a loot
box and finding that hot pink top hat
you always wanted can feel more like a
win than buying it outright even if you
spent more to get it do these strategies
work on everyone
no but they don't have to a study in
found that almost half of all spending
on mobile game microtransactions came
from 0.19% of players with a very small
number known in the industry as Wales
spending thousands on their favorite
games so in fact these companies are
okay with most people enjoying their
product for free as long as they can
soak a handful of super addicted gamers
unfortunately a lot of these whales turn
out to be calves that's what you call a
baby whale yes children are uniquely
susceptible to these psychological
tricks probably due to their impulsivity
and lack of understanding of what
they're actually doing you've probably
heard the horror stories the
seventeen-year-old who racked up $7,500
on his dad's credit card from
microtransactions in FIFA 16 or the
seven-year-old who spent $6,000 on
Jurassic world for iPad game developers
typically refuse to refund these charges
and still have not done much in the way
of child protections however there has
been some pushback from parents
legislators and gamers alike eh weak
tits reward system for the popular Star
Wars themed game battlefront 2 in
response to player criticism the game
heavily advertised Darth Vader and Luke
Skywalker as playable characters but one
gamer calculated that unless you're
willing to pay for shortcuts unlocking
the characters will require 40 hours of
in-game grinding
each and legislators in states and
countries across the world have
considered regulating Luke boxes like a
form of gambling especially now the
secondary markets have sprung up where
people can sell the rare contents of
these loop boxes for hundreds or
thousands of real dollars and indeed
research has pointed towards a link
between the amount one spends on loop
boxes and the likelihood of having a
gambling problem if you're a parent you
might consider only buying games for
your kids that are pay once and play or
at the very least avoid having any
credit card accounts linked to gaming
devices if you are a consumer of video
games yourself
remember that enjoying a game is not the
same as being addicted and like most
non-essential expenses you should keep
track of exactly how much you're
spending on it a month microtransaction
purchases are designed to be impulsive
and thoughtless so just being aware of
what you're doing is still the best meta
that's what such a noob okay stop
and that's our two cents if you're
willing to share in the comments what's
the most you've ever spent in a video
game
you
[Music]